autre sujet brûlant entre les mains du
conseil d'état l'avenir de la réforme de
l'assurance chômage
les syndicats plaident aujourd'hui pour
une suspension de la réforme pour un
terme obtenir son annulation mais le
gouvernement a lancé au dernier moment
il hier un décret correctifs qui ne
pénaliserait pas les personnes ayant
connu un congé maladie maternité ou
encore du chômage partiel
on retrouve tout de suite c'est notre
reporter lui qu'à gérer plus qu'un léger
pour en parler bonjour lucas quels sont
les enjeux de cette journée est bien
derrière les murs du conseil d'état qui
se trouve derrière moi se joue une
audience cruciale dans la lutte contre
cette réforme de l'assurance-chômage une
réforme qui est dans les tuyaux depuis
2000 19 mai qui doit rentrer en
application à partir du 1er juillet
parce qu'il ya eu entre temps a bien sûr
la crise du coc vie de 19 plusieurs
syndicats ont déposé un recours parce
qu'ils estiment que des personnes vont
être floués à salaire égal vont perdre
beaucoup d'allocations juste que juste
jusqu'à 1,15 million de personnes selon
l'étude de l'unedic que vont toucher en
moyenne 17% en moins d'allocations
chômage s'ils n'ont pas travaillé toute
l'année des chiffres qui sont toutefois
contestés par elisabeth bande qui dit
que cette baisse à les compenser et bien
par des périodes de perception plus
longue pour ces personnes je vous
propose d'écouter denis gravouille de la
cgt qui est venu aujourd'hui plaider sa
cause devant le conseil d'état
on aime band c'est très bien que c'est
complètement faux parce que le but des
économies le but de cet axe de cette
réforme c'est de faire les économies sur
le dos des chômeurs donc on leur baisse
leurs droits par mois il ya des gens qui
vont passer de 900 à 600 euros ou à 500
euros voire à 0 euros par mois et on
leur dit non mais votre capital de droit
il sera pas entamée
sauf que pour certaines personnes la wii
sera pas entamée mais fort à 90 ans pour
les cuisez donc dans les fêtes les gens
n'arriveront pas à toucher leur capital
de droit ils ont retrouvé du boulot
avant où ils seront morts avant et donc
c'est bien pour ça que madame bornes
ment éhontément depuis le début de cette
réforme c'est une réforme qui a été
écrite par les gens qui savent ni lire
ni écrire ni compter
on va le prouver aux besoins d'état le
gouvernement a prévu des planchers
pour aussi limiter cette baisse de
perception des allocations chômage pour
les personnes concernées mais rien de
cela ne suffit pour notamment la cgt et
les détracteurs du texte qui estime qu
il est inadmissible de d'appliquer cette
réforme alors même que la crise du coc
vite 19 a plongé de nombreuses personnes
dans la précarité aujourd'hui les
détracteurs du texte il espère que le
conseil d'état va suspendre donc ce
décret d'application
puis ensuite lancé une autre procédure
pour se prononcer sur le fond et
peut-être procéder à l'annulation pure
et simple de cette réforme
merci beaucoup lui cas légers en direct
du conseil d'état